les filles
son lit renouvellement
nous
ça
des marion 7
cette réunion qui se tient vous le savez
à peu à peu quelques encablures du sujet
que nous allons évoquer puisqu'il s'agit
de vous dire comment les choses vont se
dérouler s'agissant de la restauration
de la cathédrale avant de rentrer dans
le vif du sujet de de passer la parole à
mes voisins je voudrais les les
présenter en espérant ne pas le faire de
louper vous les avez sur les sur les
planches donc monsieur pascal prenait
qui est architecte en chef des monuments
historiques
madame valérie godard qui est
conservatrice régionale des monuments
historiques
évidemment monsieur philippe par baky et
directeur général des patrimoines au
ministère de la culture
marc bourhis qui est directeur régional
des affaires culturelles et manuelles et
etienne qui est sous directeur des
monuments historiques et des espaces
protégés la direction qu'anime philippe
bas monsieur philippe schirrhein qui est
chef de l'inspection des patrimoines et
puis le contrôleur général ferlay chef
du service départemental d'incendié et
de secours et le père chrono alors
j'hésite toujours sur vos titres et
fonction de ce que vous faites l'intérim
de l'évêque mais ça suffit pas à mon
sens
voilà très bien comme ça c'est un terme
laïque dans un univers séculier bien
l'objet de la réunion il est triple je
reviendrai très rapidement parce que ce
sont les éléments qui nous permettent
d'être là aujourd'hui sur l'événement
qui a été géré le 18 juillet dernier et
le contrôleur général ferlay sera votre
disposition pour faire du son ou donner
des explications complémentaires mais je
les dis très clairement l'essentiel de
la réunion n'est pas le passé
l'essentiel de la réunion c'est de vous
dire quelle est l'organisation qui va
être mise en place pour gérer le
chantier de restauration
quelles sont les étapes à venir et le
notamment la question du du phasage et
puis quel son je réduis commencer par ça
quel est le constat que l'on peut faire
sur l'état de ce bâtiment emblématique
alors je voudrais avant de passer la
parole à à monsieur philippe harbart bas
et le remercier sincèrement est revenu
le train est un lien commode à défaut de
l'avion je voudrais revenir à l'instant
sur têt sur les événements du du 18
juillet c'est évidemment un événement
dramatique qui touchent la communauté
des croyants qui est affectataire de ce
dieu et je crois très sincèrement toute
la population nantaise quitte attaché à
ce à ce monument
nous savons
les enjeux d'une restauration et
j'allais dire plus l'événement a été
dramatique plus notre responsabilité
collective celle des pouvoirs publics
celle de l'état en l'occurrence qui
d'être à la manoeuvre
c'est de conduire le chantier avec
toutes les expertises nécessaires avec
toute la sérénité nécessaire avec toute
la transparence nécessaire et en sachant
que cette question là va se poser sur le
court et le moyen terme une reviendrons
sur ce que veut dire le moyen terme
le rôle des médias est tout à fait
essentielle et je vous remercie de
l'avoir c'est à dire une fois de plus
joué par worley par vos questions
puisque vous avez contribué que ce soit
les médias écrits les médias télévisuels
les médias radios à éclairer nos
concitoyens et dire ce qui doit être dit
je voudrais préciser tout de suite que
il y à une enquête judiciaire
vous l'avez remarqué en vertu du
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
le procureur public qui conduit une
enquête n'est pas là aujourd'hui
et parce qu'il ya une enquête judiciaire
en cours
il ya toute une série de questions
auxquelles ne répondrons pas et donc je
pense que vous éviterez de les poser
d'une certaine manière parce que nous ne
sommes pas le bon guichet je voudrais
indiquer que tout ce qui est fait tout
ce qui est dit là et toutes les
expertises qui vont être annoncés le
sont en plein accord avec l'autorité
judiciaire qui d'ailleurs en aura
connaissance mais il ya une
complémentarité parfaite des autorités
avec des restrictions d'accès
actuellement puisque toutes les
expertises judiciaires ne sont pas
terminée loin de là mais quand nous vous
dirons que l expertise qui va se
réaliser dans l école conditions cela
est fait en plein accord avec le
l'autorité judiciaire et le procureur de
la république
alors je viens à l'instant sur la
question des événements et
je le fais sous l'oeil vigilant du
contrôleur général ferlay qui a été le
patron des secours mais un patron c'est
pas lui qui va dire que ça a bien marché
ça a plus de poids quand c'est
l'autorité administrative qui peut
rendre hommage vous l'avez écrit cela a
été dit par le premier ministre par la
ministre la culture par le ministre de
l'intérieur les jeudis en tant que
représentant du gouvernement ici les
opérations qui ont été conduites ont été
longs et et de manière exemplaire je
vous donne quelques points de repères
l'incendié a été signalé par un riverain
un secteur 43 les premiers moyens ont
été engagés quatre minutes plus tard en
bénéficiant d'un facteur c'est que la
caserne principale de 400 m 500 m
peut-être de la cathédrale qui simplifie
l'accès le feu a été éteint à 10h27
au total 211 personnel ont été nommés
mobilisés sur cette intervention et 84
engins dont une partie venait d'ailleurs
de plusieurs centres de secours ont
indiqué que au même moment se produisait
un accident grave
100 morts d'ailleurs sur une autoroute
qui mène à à la roche sur yon qui a à
bordeaux et l'as l'efficacité du 10 se
mesure aussi à sa capacité à répondre
aux événements qui se produisent en
dehors même de la de la crise que l'on
vit
les dégâts sur lesquels philippe barba
et ses équipes reviendront ont été on
peut le dire contenu et de ce point de
vue le drame qui avait été vécue il ya
moins de 20 ans si le compte est bon
trente ans pardon 2072 48 envoyé le le
temps s'écrase dans les mémoires 48 ans
mais les décisions qui avaient été
prises à l'époque ont permis de
sauvegarder l'essentiel mais c'est aussi
grâce aux parfums au professionnalisme
des sapeurs-pompiers et je vous le dis
je voudrais le dire également ne s'agit
pas seulement d'intervention dans
l'immédiat mais également grâce à la
qualité de la préparation en amont les
plans de sauvegarde le plan de
sauvegarde qui est connu et est
opérationnel
le plan d'intervention l'était également
et pour ce qui est la préfecture une
réunion s'était tenue le 29 octobre 2019
pour comme on dit chez qu'est la qualité
du plan sécurité
ajoutons que le contrôle des
installations électriques avait été fait
comme ça devait être le cas venait
d'être fait par la pav
et puis et j'en terminerai par cela
peut-être en devançant des questions que
vous poserez il faut rappeler que cet
édifice est régulièrement entretenu
je donne les chiffres parce qu'ils sont
tout à fait important c'est un montant
de plus de 20 millions d'euros qui a été
alloué à l'entretien et l'entretien
lourd de ce bâtiment en une vingtaine
d'années
sans compter les frais d'entretien
courants comme les hauteurs de 20
millions d'euros
ceux là sont plus plus modestes voilà
donc le j'allais dire le la situation
que nous avons à gérer et encore une
fois les dégâts ont été contenus
l'intervention des services de l'état et
je voudrais signaler également le rôle
des collectivités locales qui ont
sont le lieu d'accueil je vous le dirai
pas où c'est pas la peine de le mettre
dans la presse mais de ce qu'on appelle
le trésor de la cathédrale et de divers
autres biens précieux
ils sont répartis à la fois dans les
locaux de la mairie et dans les sites
détenus par le conseil départemental
voilà un peu comment les uns et les
autres seront articulés leur
intervention pour en arriver à la
situation que nous connaissons
je pense que le plus simple monsieur des
taux général c'est que puisque c'est la
maison ministère la culture qui est
propriété du bâtiment qui avec l'appui
des services déconcentrés va va gérer ce
dossier trouvais cela la main pour la
suite de notre réunion beaucoup monsieur
le préfet
bonjour vous avez évoqué monsieur le
café d'abord la question du constable
j'ai pu me rendre ce matin avec mes
collègues du ministère de la culture à
la cathédrale
c'est toujours un spectacle difficile et
louve ans pour toute personne qui aime
le patrimoine spécialistes ou non de
constater les dégâts importants se sont
intervenus à la suite de cette envie-là
la destruction de l'or vous le savez la
disparition complète d'un tableau qui
était protégé au titre des monuments
historiques
les dégâts causés à des objets qui a été
conservé également dans la crypte donc
nous sommes aussi face à un événement
patrimoniale graves à des détériorations
également sont plus portés sur certains
éléments du matif de la cathédrale
notamment la verrière axial j'ai pu le
constater de près ce matin vraiment les
dégâts ont été très importants et face à
cette cet épisode qui effectivement même
s'il n'est pas de même ampleur
n'était pas sans rappeler ce que j'avais
pu vivre personnellement et un certain
nombre d'entre nous autour de cette
table lors de l' incendie de notre dame
est bien à paris nous avons constaté la
même mobilisation immédiate
bien sûr des forces avec lesquelles nous
avons la chance de travailler sur
lesquelles nous avons la chance de
pouvoir compter notamment les sapeurs
pompiers c'était le cas notre dame mais
ça a été le cas aussi lors de cet
épisode
je tiens il fait mais une fois de plus
au nom du ministère de la culture toute
la gratitude de notre ministère pour ses
forces qui sont toujours présentes dans
ces dans ces événements là mais aussi la
mobilisation très rapide de tout là la
famille du patrimoine ce que j'appelle
la famille du patrimoine est alors bien
entendu ce sont des fonctionnaires des
agents publics
celles et ceux des drags des directions
régionales des affaires culturelles mais
aussi les architecte en chef des
monuments historiques la salle trenet
est ici l'architecte des bâtiments de
france responsable unique de sécurité de
la cathédrale bref toute une famille de
professionnels très fort mais qui dans
les minutes dans les heures qui ont
suivi le début de l'incendié se sont
immédiatement au groupe et pour venir au
secours de cet édifice
et c'est dans ces moments là que nous
savons
vous trouvez nous retrouver pour agir
d'une manière la plus rapide possible la
plus efficace avec tout ce travail de
préparation vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le préfet qui a été fait avec les
sapeurs-pompiers et qui a permis de
contenir en effet les dégâts qui
auraient pu être encore bien plus grand
chacune et chacun autour de cette table
qui étaient sur le terrain aura
l'occasion d'apporter les précisions que
vous souhaitez mais cette famille du
patrimoine c'est aussi le secteur privé
c'est aussi les entreprises qui se sont
mobilisés tout de suite les entreprises
spécialisées dans la restauration du
patrimoine qui a été présente là prédit
l'après midi même et qui sont toujours
présentes au chevet de l'édifice atteint
ce sont les professionnels les
scientifiques les conservateurs
restaurateurs les experts qui
travaillent pour sauver aussi ces
éléments de patrimoine extrêmement
précieux et donc c'est grâce à cette
mobilisation collective de cette famille
du patrimoine secteur public secteur
privé quelles que soient les statuts
quelles que soient les différences entre
les personnes que aujourd'hui nous
sommes arrivés à préserver je dirais
l'essentiel il nous reste maintenant à
décliner ce que va être dans les dans
les mois et dans les années qui viennent
le travail
les services de l'état et vous expliquer
à vous faire comprendre ce qu'est ce
système d'intervention des
professionnels du patrimoine qui va se
déployer et pour cela je vais passer la
parole
d'abord à marcq le bourhis le directeur
régional des affaires culturelles
parce que vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le préfet la drac est un monument qui
appartient à l'état qui est confiée au
ministère de la culture comme les autres
cathédrales de notre pays et c'est là
gracq la direction régionale des
affaires culturelles s'est exercé la
maîtrise d ouvrage
donc c'est elle sur également la
responsabilité de l'ensemble des travaux
qui vont être menées aussi bien sur le
batik sur le mobilier donc marque va
vous décrire et déployer des différentes
phases dans lesquelles ce travail va pas
s'organiser parce que je te passe la
parole
merci philippe
marc le bris c'est un directeur régional
donc moi je
c'est un peu le généraliste de l'état et
donc je vais passer très vite la parole
aux sachants spécialistes grandes phases
amont somatique
c'est simple si vous n'avez pas déplacé
à chaque fois les micros les scellés la
tiens on va faire la fête ou là moi ça
va prendre deux trois minutes mais après
ça c'est pas ça sera guérie d'aller avec
pascal couillaud bas ils viendront après
moi ça va être très très rapide n'est
pas grave a laissé le tout l'art de
l'intervention de la drac maîtrise
d'ouvragé je vais parler en une telle
mesure
la première unité de mesure ça sera en
semaines il est impossible de vous dire
au nom précis de semaine que ça sera le
trail de l'enquète et de la police
scientifique mais on n'en parlera pas
comme l'indiqué monsieur le préfet pour
nous ça sera très vite des possibles de
sécuriser le monument pour me
mettre à l'abri les personnels qui ont
besoin d'intervenir
ça sera de mener les expertises qui ont
déjà commencé on vous pourra vous
apporter des détails tout à l'heure à
l'instinct et puis identification et
mises à l'abri
un des restes des du monument et des
oeuvres donc la deuxième unité de mesure
elle sera en moins ça sera celle des
diagnostics et des études qu'on souhaite
effectivement le
période la plus courte possible et là
pascal brunet pourra s'engager bien sûr
mais donner un ordre d'idée et puis
après la dernière unité de mesure ça
sera en année et là ça sera là la
période de la reconstruction
donc je passe maintenant la parole à
avaler riffs qui va nous apporter plus
de détails sur les expertises et sur les
choses d un engagement
peut-être le boost rentiers on y
présente le constructeur présente
constat de secours
si vous voulez bien en quelques mots
avant que parce qu'elle prenait rentre
plus en avant dans le constat sur
notamment l'état de la façade
je vais vous déclinez effectivement
cette première phase qui est la phase de
sécurisation avant d'aborder la deuxième
phase afin d'expertiser cette phase de
sécurisation pourquoi parce que on a une
façade occidentale donc là que vous
voyez qui s'ouvre sur le parvis
cette façade occidentale qui est qui a
énormément souffert par le fait donc de
l'apport intense de chaleur au revers de
7-2 cette façade avec l' incendie qui a
touché le grand orgue l'ordre de la
tribune donc delà de la cathédrale cette
façade donc le feu fait créer d'un effet
donc d'éclatement de la pierre et donc
les minots de la grande verrière les
pierres de l'ensemble de cette façade
sont fortement altérée fortement altérée
signifie que du coup les pierres sont
instables et pierre étant instable
il faut donc procéder à différentes
phases je dirais
de sécurisation qui sont en cours en ce
moment phase de sécurisation qui a
consisté premièrement à m un périmètre
de sécurité
vous l'avez vu mis en place à la fois
sur le parvis dans sa totalité mais
également avec des grilles her as donc
infranchissable réputées
infranchissables plus de façon un peu
plus raccrocher autour de la façade zone
de danger pour l'instant ne peut pas y
aller raison de danger pour essayer de
lever au plus vite ce danger en ce
moment vous l'avez sans doute vu nous
avons donc demandé à ce que l'entreprise
avec nacelle interviennent nous sommes
en train de purger
c'est à dire de d'enlever les partie de
la façade qui sont sains qui sont
instables notamment les mines au delà
de la grande verrière si les purgeant si
nous les purges en patience nous
n'enlevons pas les morceaux nous cercle
où ses morceaux pour qu'ils puissent
tenir
donc être maintenue solidairement avec
avec l'ensemble de la maçonnerie ensuite
ce sera donc à filer un défilé même de
protection qui seront donc tendue face
interne face externe pour pouvoir donc
maintenir éventuellement et et
faire pièce aux maîtriser le risque
éventuel de chutes de pierres ainsi que
un filet qui sera tendue également au
dessus
donc là je passe à l'intérieur au dessus
de la tribune d'orgue pour également
faire une sorte de parc graves voies en
quelque sorte pourquoi pour pouvoir très
rapidement permettre l'accès à la
tribune la tribune de l'orgue
c'est en effet le lieu où se sont
écroulés les vestiges donc va alors de
lui même
il est donc aujourd'hui nous avons à cet
endroit là un amas de bois de pierre de
tuyaux d'orgue un évidement tous ont été
constitués
cet orgue à cet endroit là une fois que
le para voie sera ce filet sera pendue
les équipes de la police judiciaire
pourront intervenir
donc là nous aurons un ensemble qui sera
sécurisé
ça c'est la première phase cette
sécurisation la deuxième phase ensuite
alors en stabilisation les dégâts se
sont principalement se concentre
principalement sur ces parties là
la deuxième phase dont qui est la
deuxième le deuxième assez de ces
premiers travaux que nous menons donc
dans au cours de cette semaine c'est la
phase d expertise il y à déjà donc une
restauratrice de textile qui est arrivé
très rapidement dès le samedi
elle était là à samedi 17h elle est
venue en j'ai des milliers textile très
sexy halle qui avait reçu un peu d'eau
dans au cours de la fin donc ça fait
déjà partie s'est déjà sous contrôle
chez une restauratrice les autres
expertises que nous avons commandé c'est
effectivement savoir quel est l'état
général des oeuvres qui restent à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale des
maçonneries qui sont en place et donc
pour vous donner un peu de tempo de tout
ce qui se passe pendant cette semaine
c'est constat d'état sur les peintures
sur toile qui a été effectuée par deux
ateliers de peinture de restauration de
peintures locaux donc deux personnes qui
sont sur sur nantes qui sont passés hier
qui ont fait un constat l'état général
de toutes les peintures de la cathédrale
toutes les huiles sur toile de la
cathédrale également aujourd'hui une
personne un restaurateur de structure
qui vient expertiser le tombeaux des
ducs de bretagne
il se trouvait en effet à proximité d'un
des lieux de foyers donc
incendies est donc nous avons diligenté
une expertise spécifique sur sur ce
tombeau autre expert qui passe
aujourd'hui quand je dis aujourd'hui
c'était ce matin nous les avons vus à
l'oeuvre le un expert concernant le
climat intérieur
donc c'est à dire pour essayer de
mesurer quel est le taux d'hygrométrie
et le taux et la température à
l'intérieur donc de la cathédrale donc
des capteurs sont posés dans la
cathédrale pourquoi parce qu'il a là
aussi non seulement vous parle du feu
mais il ya aussi l'eau et donc un apport
d'humidité importants à l'intérieur de
la cathédrale avec forcément une
incidence sur les oeuvres d'art l'autre
experts qui étaient là également
aujourd'hui c'est un expert horde
pourquoi parceque il
il connaît très bien lord qui a
aujourd'hui disparu
il peut nous aider à retrouver des
morceaux et identifier des morceaux du
buffet d'orgues qui que nous avons perdu
son analyse est donc extrêmement
précieuse et également il y à un autre
ordre qui est lors de coeur qui se
trouvait lui aussi à proximité d'un
foyer et donc il doit nous dire ce qu'il
en est de l'état de cet ordre encore je
vais décliner les experts qui passe
cette semaine demain
quatre experts qui seront également
présents ils viennent tous les quatre du
laboratoire de recherche des monuments
historiques
monsieur barba a eu l'occasion de vous
dire combien la grande famille des
monuments historiques se mobilisaient
effectivement pour au chevet de cette
cathédrale pour cet incendie et
notamment donc le laboratoire de
recherche des monuments historiques sous
le
qui appartient au ministère de la
culture a mobilisé son pôle d'expertisé
en microbiologie
pourquoi parce que nous avons beaucoup
de bois qui ont été égorgés d'eau qui
ont subi à combustion et il faut
aujourd'hui connaître à savoir quel est
l'état effectivement de c2c bois de
conte comment ils vont vivre à partir de
maintenant et quelques errements des
remèdes éventuellement on doit apporter
à leur éventuelle pathologie expertise
pierre de taille vous pouvez imaginer
dans le diagnostic la description que
j'ai fait de la notamment de la façade
combien cela nous sera précieux les
pierres ont éclaté peut-on les conserver
ou pas voilà c'est l' expertise car de
taille qui pourra nous le dire du
laboratoire de recherche des monuments
historiques expertise vitrail également
pourquoi parce que la grande verrière a
été soufflée par l' incendie et donc il
y a dispersés un peu partout des
morceaux de cette grande verrière qui
comme vous le savez et est constitué à
la fois de vitrail blanc de restauration
donc trahi relativement récent mais sur
plus de 3 dans cette qui date est dû au
début du 16e siècle
donc qui sont aujourd'hui que nous avons
à coeur évidemment dont nous avons à
coeur de rechercher les différents
morceaux et puis dernière experte qui
est présente métal expertise métal
justement pour l'analyse notamment des
plombs de ceux de ce vitrail les plombs
sont toujours sont toujours là les
tuyaux de l'orgue éventuellement voilà
éventuellement une fort on passait donc
par la suite un expert sur la sculpture
sculpture en oeuvre il y avait également
des parties sculptées dans cette
cathédrale
j'aimerais connaître en effet l'état des
sculptures qui sont sous la tribune par
exemple et puis autre expertise que nous
avons commandé les peintures murales
il y à des peintures murales à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale
je ne pense pas on ne l'a pas ciblé
comme une priorité parce que sincèrement
là
la voilà ses peintures n'auront sans
doute pas énormément souffert x et tous
ces experts viennent apporter à la
demande du maître d'ouvragé que je
représente avec le préfet le directeur
régional à notre demande
ils viennent donc faire des constats
d'état des diagnostics sanitaires sur
ces sommes leur île
leur expertise sera donc consignées dans
des rapports qu'ils vont nous remettre
leur avons bien évidemment vous
l'imaginez demandé d'être rapide mais il
faut tout de même le temps du travail c
est que ces rapports rendus nous nous
les analyserons et ensuite nous en
tirerons les conséquences
pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
effectivement des actions de
conservation
donc ça c'est ce qui va se dérouler que
dirait dans les semaines qui vont qui
vont suivre
je vous ai signalé qu'il y avait déjà
les actions de conservation qui était en
route avec notamment la pièce textile
donc que j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
mais il y a donc cessé actions qui
seront qui se dérouleront peu à peu au
fur à mesure d urgence également qui
nous seront signalés donc nous sommes en
attente pour ces rapports nous sommes en
attente c'est la commande qui a été
passée aux différents experts et
restaurateurs d'avoir en quelque sorte
un plan d'action déterminées par
l'urgence c'est la demande ensuite donc
ces actions de conservation
au-delà de ces actions de conservation
nous travaillerons et nous travaillons
déjà bien évidemment
vous le savez avec l'architecte en chef
des monuments historiques qui va donc
également un autre demande faite en chef
des monuments historiques
pascal fournier est le maître d'oeuvre
pour pour pour l'état pour la drague sur
cette cathédrale
il va nous faire des propositions de
d'intervention plus lourdes sur
notamment la façade de la cathédrale
nous avons pu faire grâce àla nacelle
des expertises déjà sur 7 sur cette
façade et je pense qu'il est temps que
je ne vais pas sa parole pour une
technique vous avez pu voir ce que vous
envisagez il va lui proposer de venir
ici je veux pas vous chasser mais c'est
plus simple micro
j'hésite beaucoup de choses ont été vite
j'ai préparé un type powerpoint pour une
réunion de travail qui avait vu à la
préfecture il ya deux jours les choses
n'ont pas beaucoup évolué et donc je
vous présenterai quelques unes de ses
photos
je voulais juste rappeler que dès samedi
dès samedi avec les sapeurs pompiers il
ya eu une action de sauvegarde sur la
façade sud qui a été menée par les
témoins de la grande baie sud
en fait ce bébé est instable et grâce
aux moyens des sapeurs pompiers et à
l'existence de l'entreprise le fait
qu'on peut appeler une restauration des
monuments historiques y travaillent sur
le chantier en pierre de taille
on a pu tout de suite mettre en place
des éléments de stabilisation de cette
baisse donc je vais pas revenir sur
toutes les propositions de sauvegarde
qui ont été présentés par valérie godard
mais cette la façade sud aujourd'hui et
déjà d'une certaine façon sécurisée ça
n'est pas terminé il va falloir
renforcer les choses mais néanmoins lé
horde dents
hi media il ya quand même pour rappeler
les façades occidentale oui est il donc
c'est bien la façade ouest n'est pas la
façade sud il faut il ya trois points
trois hommes de tous subi un incendie
dans la cathédrale et qui sont forcément
trois zones de traumatismes la plus
grande et la plus importante est
probablement la plus signifiante
c'est celle de la façade ouest parce que
la façade ouest
c'est le point de départ de cette
cathédrale
c'est le début de la construction du 15e
siècle de la cathédrale voulu par
françois ii le dernier des ducs de
bretagne et que cannes
cette fille un hautbois tag reine de
france a essayé de cacher qu'elle n'a
pas chômé puisque c est resté inachevé
jusqu'au 19ème siècle au niveau du
transept après avoir continué sa
construction est conservé son titre man
et l'église actuelle elle est en partie
19e en moins pour toute la partie du
trans est au chevet donc cette partie de
la façade occidentale
c'est évidemment
le patrimonial a plus la plus précieuse
dans l'histoire l'architecturé de la
cathédrale et il y avait dans la façade
sud le grand vitrail qui a explosé
exploser c'est le terme qui nous a été
rapporté par les par les pompiers je
pense que personne en tout cas ici il a
été témoin de cette explosion mais c'est
un vrai sujet parce que les verts sont
en très petit fragment on espère entre
les plus grands il y avait le trois
éléments de vie troupe du 16e siècle
majeur dans cette grande verrière qui
comportait comme une rondelette l'une
blanche
pour le reste et qui donc une certaine
manière était dans un état partie
culturelle inachevé on pourrait dire il
y avait évidemment l'or ne vais pas
revenir sur l'orgue gp le spécialiste de
l'or mais de l'or il me reste que des
fragments qui sont en cours d'expertisé
dont on espère retrouver cependant un
certain nombre de morceaux de sculptures
conserver parce que le bois était à
l'abri le visage de la sculpture contre
le sol protégé de l'incendié parfois
donc ça c'est quand même un espoir
donc on a deux deux espoirs de recherche
qui sont d'une part essayer de refaire
un puzzle comme ça a pu être fait par
exemple à la cathédrale de limoges pour
une belle
explosé il ya une quinzaine d'années et
il ya des maîtres verriers avec l'aide
de leurs images qui le laboratoire de
recherche des monuments historiques qui
arrive à faire ce genre de choses c'est
un travail de longue haleine
il faut que les morceaux soient pas trop
petit mais c'est pas permis
et puis évidemment le monde travaille
sur l'ordre donc on est dans cette phase
de sécurisation qui va encore durer un
petit moment
aujourd'hui on est en train de mettre en
place le filet pour éviter que que les
personnes qui est un risque de chutes de
matériaux et pour la sécurité des
personnes aux abords de la cathédrale
tant à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur pour
les personnes qui font des expertises et
on a fait en sorte que la sécurisation
de la berre de l'abbé haute soit fait
avec un minimum de purge
le terme purger d'ailleurs inappropriée
on a déposé les éléments qui était tombé
ou qui menace est tombée tout ce qui
était encore même très dégradé avec un
tant soit peu de pardon un tant soit peu
de stabilité
donc vous voyez ici la zone de la baie
tout ça c'est vous verrez une photo un
peu un peu plus un peu plus loin c'est
extrêmement instable et au dessous de
cette baisse au dessous de cette baisse
se situe le triforium ici à la galerie
du triforium et cette galerie donc c'est
un mur un vide dans un mur et à l'aplomb
de la bei ci se situer un deuxième
trimestre âge qui donnait sur la nef et
qui était dans la prolongation de tous
les meneaux donc tous ces éléments
verticaux qui structurait la veille
c'est tombé c'est parti et donc 16 mai
s'est trouvée en train de peser tout à
coup dans le vide voilà ces affaires
alors une photo du même endroit
ici vous voyez la belle et riche orium
qui a elle aussi suivi le feu elle était
protégée par le premier fenestraz qui
était du côté de la nef est néanmoins
tous les vitraux ont aussi explosé dans
cette zone et donc il ya une deuxième
course 6 est un peu plus bas derrière le
gâble du grand portail et qui recèle
probablement des vestiges de
de ces vitraux et des pierres tombées un
petit peu plus près on voit ici je sais
pas si vous arrivez à le voir mais il ya
une fissure
cette fissure court tout le long de ces
pierres de granit qui compte que l'on
voit encore ici et qui constitue la
coursive au niveau de l'appui des
beyrouth
donc cette coursive elle est en appui
sur la façade du côté ouest et les
suspendus
du côté est on se rend pas bien compte
sur cette photo mais maintenant il ya
des éléments qui sont derrière et qui
ont été posées samedi par les pompiers
voilà cette même si sûr quand on regarde
ça en impression que cette partie là est
descendu et bien non cette partie là
n'est pas descendu c'est cette partie ci
qui s'est soulevée sous le poids de la
baie qui est en arrière plantes connues
intérieur de la cathédrale voilà une vue
du réseau dans la partie haute vous
voyez le les flammes que j'aurais pu
voir sur les différents documents qui
ont été publiés traverser cette phase
tout le vitrail est tombé il ne reste
plus que des fragments qui sont scellés
encore dans les monos et d'ennui maribel
mais ce que vous voyez ici c'est un
phénomène qui a eu lieu par dilatation
thermique et peut-être hydriques au
moment de l'extinction d'un incendie et
peut-être par dilatation des métaux et
là il ya des grandes élément qui peut
être en deux ou trois endroits traverse
échelle
l'ensemble de la façade de la cathédrale
et la relier au tour ces éléments se
retourne d'ailleurs dans les baies du
triforium à l'étagé inférieur également
donc ces éléments sont dilatées ce sont
dilatées sous le feu et ça fait exploser
pardon ça fait exploser les pierres
voyez ici toutes les pierres tout et
modénatures un peu seyante se sont
décollées et un certain nombre d'entre
elles sont était encore être mon fragile
donc tous ces éléments ont été dans la
mesure du possible ligaturer pour de
permettre une analyse du tranquillement
une fois que l'ensemble sera sécurisée
sans avoir à comment dire augmenter la
perte matérielle et la perte de
lisibilité de l ouvrage est une chose
qu'on peut voir par là qu'ils allaient
qu'on peut voir encore ici c'est que on
a une ouverture et en fait l'ensemble de
deux cd de ce rang plage on appelle ça
un grand plat de ce réseau est descendu
d'environ 2 cm par rapport à sa position
initiale
est ce qu'on a pu voir aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas dans cette photo c'est qu'on a
une fissure en dollar qu'au niveau de la
clé qui remonte dans l'union
donc il est bien dit mouvement
probablement même encore depuis les
événements qu'on a mises en place samedi
et qui montre qu'il faut bien
aujourd'hui assez rapidement renforcée
c'était tellement ce qui va être fait
dans les jours qui viennent
voilà ici vous voyez l'intérieur au
revers de la façade
voyez la grande baie ouest la tribune
d'orgue la tribune a été traversée par
les eaux d'extinction c'est pour ça que
tout est très sombre ici il n'y a pas eu
de feu mais les odac tension de
l'incendié ont traversé les gouttes et
30 détrempée l'ensemble des boutin et
les nervures cependant la tribune semble
stable on va la mettre sous surveillance
et s'il y avait une éventuelle nécessité
eh bien on les verra dans les prochains
jours on voit ici les vestiges du
positif de l'orgue et puis d'un côté il
ya la même chose de l'autre des vestiges
du grand buffet qui sont adossés ici à
la façade nord on a un vide entre la la
tribune et la façade des tours tous
permettra de monter des échafaudages de
pied assez rapidement sur les côtés
également pour pouvoir faire l'expertisé
des parties hautes
alors on voit pas très bien parce qu'il
y avait encore de la fumée sur c'est
quand on a que les prises plus tôt mais
en fait on s'aperçoit que très haut rayé
ici les nervures les événements des
façades
voyez ici ont perdu une partie de leurs
maudits nature les baies du triforium
sont sur les côtés des tours nord et sud
sont elles même assez dégradé et ici on
voit les étaiements mais ces éléments de
métal qui ont été mises en place par les
pompiers et
l'abeille du triforium qui a vraiment
disparu ce qui fait que la base de la bo
tu es et déposés dans le vide
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a trouvé samedi
dans les heures qui ont suivi les
minutes qui ont suivi l'incendié
on a la même chose de l'autre côté vous
voyez ici encore des éléments de
nervures qui sont partis et un certain
nombre d'entre eux sont instables
voilà la grande la grande baie du
triforium dans la halle dans la face à
l'ouest avec ce qui reste de la
balustrade
voyez ici les pierres du mur elles mêmes
sont des plaques est extrêmement
dégradée des tec ont émis amis
profondeur amis épaisseur du triforium
et qu'on va probablement devoir
remplacer en déposant les vrais du strad
pour le mettre à l'aplomb de la bo t
assurer une meilleure transition des
forces duo ou au support qui est au
dessous voilà encore les éléments de
dégradations qui ont lieu avec le feu on
espère que les routes ne sont pas
touchées elles n'ont pas l'air mais bon
le ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
températures sont très hautes
au niveau des voûtes la chaleur monte et
il ya des éliminations de chaleur en
partie haute à notre-dame des
températures de entre 100 et 1000 degrés
sur le sud et voûtes 11 millions 100
degrés et dans la phrase est de plus de
12 100 degrés voilà parmi les expertises
ont pour le solliciter ou ski l'école
normale supérieure qu'il fait une
expertise à notre dame sur les charbons
qui nous ont donné des des température
de combustion des bois c'était très
intéressant parce que cela permet de
comprendre de corréler ça avec
l'altération des pierres de parement
pardon voilà encore
le mur nord et je ne sais pas si vous
voyez ça c'est cette lan 7 qui est ici
et au niveau du départ de la route voilà
ce qui peut arriver on a une pierre qui
est accroché et qui est une manière
extrêmement précaire entre deux airs dur
donc ces lieux sont dangereux mais c'est
pour ça que l'on va mettre en place un
filet pour pouvoir le faire que nous dit
valérie godard les expertises
nécessaires
ça c'est l'une des baies du triforium du
côté nord et vous voyez ici et pierre
qui sont complètement décoller de leur
support voilà ces éléments là dedans -
quand ils tiennent on les ligatures et
on les laisse en place pour avoir plus
d'éléments denali pour les culés voilà
donc ici les visions qu'on a depuis le
triforium delà de la tour nord de
l'ensemble des vestiges de l'orgue les
pierres qui sont tombés tout pendant
toutes les pièces y sont tombés du
triforium de la baie ouest et on voit à
droite on voit à droite les vestiges de
de la balustrade en fer
les vestiges de du positif de l'ordre
qui se classe et là dedans avec quelques
chances des éléments et des vitraux et
des éléments sérieux des sculptures de
porn city on a du coeur avec l'orgue qui
a été épargnée langue de coeur et la
deuxième travée qui a été incendié avec
les mêmes domaines d'altération sur les
deux piles du coeur probablement plus
limité aux parties inférieures et on
voit la dégradation sur la façade
face à qui est partiellement noir qui
probablement un peu dans le bas-côté
aussi est en fait on ne sait pas s'il ya
eu des incidences sur les parties hautes
l'on trouve des petits morceaux de
mortier ou parfois de pierre qui sont
tombés au sol à l'aplomb des voûtes
voilà la cathèdre encore les piliers à
gauche à droite l'un des lustres en
morceaux qui a brûlé et enfin le bras
sud du transept avec le tombeau de 2
devant perial michel collon du sculpteur
michel colombe le tombeau de françois
duhen guérite de foi qui est épargnée
par les incendies
heureusement mais bon qui est dans des
conditions précaires du fait de
l'hygrométrie relativement élevé dans la
cathédrale comme l'a souligné valérie
godard on venait de rendre une étude sur
ce tombeau il ya quelques jours qu'ils
étaient prêtes pour une consultation
d'entreprises pour la restauration est
en fait qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on a
des scènes extrêmement délétère
parce que ce tombeau était remonté au
plâtre en 1817 et iliad et celles qui
ont tendance à changer de face d'hier a
cristallisé ou est-ce solubiliser à des
forts taux d'hygrométrie et donc on est
dans un bon vin comment dire une oeuvre
d'art un signe qui est dans un état de
la très grande fragilité de près et
voilà sur laquelle on fait un diagnostic
en ce moment voilà le mur à l'aplomb du
le mur ouest du bras sud avec évidemment
on voit là des plaquages de pierre qui
sont liées à un incendie de cette zone
où kaboul voilà ce que je peux vous dire
qu'ils ont un instant dans cet état ça
rapidement de la la la zone de clôture
provisoire avec l'année celle que vous
avez pu voir ce matin il y en aura une
autre à l'intérieur ça c'est
les zones de dégâts les plus importantes
donc le triforium la grande baie les
vitraux disparu l'impact sur la façade
sud face à l'ouest par le revers de
cette façade ouest ici donc il montre
l'état sanitaire dont je vous ai parlé
sur les photos et la coupe avec le
la tribune d'orgue en partie inférieure
ici toute cette zone était effectivement
trajet lisez ok donc on va rentrer assez
bientôt dès qu'on aura terminé cette
sécurisation dans la formalisation avec
la drac de
du programme de diagnostic et
le suivi les différences des différentes
expertises
évidemment pour les réintégrer dans ce
diagnostic et puis
on rentre donc dans la phase d'étude
probablement dès la fin du mois d'août à
peu près ok merci c'est l'architecte ans
y est
est-ce qu'on avant de passer la séquence
des questions réponses
parce qu'on a un monsieur barbade et
point ajouté non et bien leurs questions
question réponse à votre va de
convenance
mesdames messieurs clichy on n'a pas su
défendre a été très clair les i alors
combien ça coûte
il n'a pas dit qui paye mais dit combien
ça coûte
monsieur merci beaucoup alors bien sûr
c'est encore bien trop tôt pour répondre
à cette question puisque comme ça vous a
été expliquée notamment par par notre
collègue fait qu'une et architecte en
chef des monuments historiques
il faut d'abord au porter un diagnostic
sur l'étendue des dégâts avec les
incertitudes qui vous ont été présentés
on a vu qu'il y avait certaines parties
de l'édifice qui était atteinte soit par
le feu soit par les écoulements d'eau
qui ont eu lieu lors de l'extinction de
l'incendié
et donc il va falloir préciser dans les
semaines les mois qui viennent quelle
est l'importance des atteintes qu'ils
ont été portés et donc savourer x est
une variable très importante en réalité
dans les coûts parce qu'on ne sait pas
si finalement tout a à peu près bien
tenu le coup on a parlé notamment des
voûtes se trouve au dessus de l'ordre
qui a acquis à brûler qu'il faudra avoir
des interventions assez lourde sur ses
voûtes et donc ça rien que ça ça peut
faire varier
je dirais la facture évidemment de
plusieurs centaines de
milliers voire de millions d'euros donc
c'est seulement au terme de ce de ces
diagnostics de ces études précises qui
seront effectués d'ailleurs à la fois
sur le bâti mais aussi ma collègue
valérie goudard la ram ne l'a rappelé
sur le mobilier de la cathédrale qui va
nécessiter aussi des interventions
importantes que nous serons en mesure de
chiffrer le montant total des travaux
qui seront à effectuer votre question
mais bon
ça y est
l'idée est là
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur la durée
une fois le diagnostic
c'est quand même un gros chantier mais
il peut y avoir peut-être trois
chantiers ici on ne sait pas encore mais
si on arrive à bien organiser les choses
le gros chantier c'est le massif
occidental c'est la partie centrale de
la baie ouest
et puis il ya peut-être deux chantiers
un peu plus restreint
qui sont celui du club
mais il ya plein d'autres problèmes
comme les bloquer valérie godard donc
c'est un peu difficile d'aujourd'hui de
dessiner mais c'est évidemment en année
c'est probablement en moins globalement
trois ans à partir de maintenant si on
pas dit si on perd pas de temps si on se
coordonne bien et s'il ya pas trop de
sujets et mais qui émerge de ces études
les villes invisibles
mais je suis plus je suis pas sûr que
travaux égale fermeture il n'y a pas de
corrélation pas forcément de corrélation
entre travaux et fermeture de l'édifice
nous allons rebondir
tentez essayer en tout cas c'est
l'objectif d'organiser le la
restauration de cet édifice pour qu' on
puisse au plus tôt et au mieux pouvoir
permettre un retour une ouverture de
l'édifice qui sera au début très partiel
puis un peu moins partiel et ensuite
voilà de plus en plus on aura une
ouverture qui sera plus large
il est trop tôt sans doute là pour en
effet faire je lance des chiffres etc
ah bon
ces chiffres sont donnés au regard de
notre connaissance de techniciens que
nous avons est principalement donc
acheté en chef des monuments historiques
mais notre attention sera bien en effet
de permettre au plus tôt de pouvoir
rouvrir au moins certaines parties et
puis également une ambition aussi sans
doute de donner à voir ce que nous
faisons c'est à dire aujourd'hui il ya
un réel book et appétence du public pour
les métiers du patrimoine
on voit comment il s'approprie aussi le
patrimoine le public
donc on essaiera au mieux là encore donc
en respectant toutes les conditions et
l'objectif premier est évidemment la
restauration du monument
mais deux
voilà de partager ces instants
il est
on vous en reparle d'ici peu merci
pour tout vous dire en effet comme ça a
été évoqué par mon collègue parce
qu'elle prenait
nous envisagions nous venons de passer
commande à monsieur prenez donc d'une
fois diagnostic mais aussi d'une mission
de maîtrise d'oeuvre pour la réalisation
de la restauration de ce tombeau
donc c'était le grand sujet de cette
cathédrale dans pour les trois ans qui
allait venir
à partir de cette année partir de la fin
de l'année nous devions à partir là de
cette deuxième moitié du mois de juillet
2020 lancer la consultation des
entreprises pour la restauration de ce
tombeau
vous comprenez bien qu'aujourd'hui avec
l'événement qui vient de se produire
nous allons avoir besoin d'un petit
temps pour savoir comment on ré axe
voilà l'ensemble des opérations que nous
allons conduire sur ce monument ne nous
l'oublions absolument pas puisque
justement la préoccupation première a
été de faire venir au plus tôt le
restaurateur de sculpture je veux citer
son nom quelqu'un d'important olivier
rolland qui vient du tour nous le
faisons venir pour justement expertiser
le
temps beau faire un constat d'état de
son état dans post incendie et une fois
qu'il nous aura remis son rapport est en
discussion avec lui avec parce qu'elle
prenait avec l'inspection général des
monuments historiques également eh bien
nous nous verrons voilà comment quel est
le programme de travaux nous affinerons
le programme des travaux au regard de la
de l'état de ce combo et des événements
donc ils viennent de se produire
m
pourquoi pas nous en serions très
heureux et friand nous comme vous l'avez
vu nous entourent ont effectivement des
meilleurs experts la richesse du
ministère de la culture ce sont la
pluralité c'est la pluralité de ses
compétences
nous avons pour tout vous dire le jour
même de l'incendié dans les minutes qui
me suivent ils incendient j'ai reçu des
tas d'informations émanant de tous mes
collègues de france pour me dire il y as
telles ressources documentaires tels
articles tels connaissance que nous
avons de la verrière de etc voilà tous
les éléments que constitue ce qui le
rend constitué par cette cathédrale et
qui auraient pu être touchés à
l'occasion de la sant dit oui nous
ferons tout pour
alors je ne sais pas ce que nous
pourront en effet découvrir peut-être
puisque nous serons vraiment très proche
du monument sur la grande verrière par
exemple mieux connaître sa mise en
oeuvre
paradoxalement mieux connaître la mise
en oeuvre de cette de cette façade par
exemple aussi connaître où vous avez vu
des morceaux de la cathèdre donc quand
tu es tâche et intérêts au sol là aussi
peut-être qu'il a restera on va
récupérer ses morceaux on va les
restaurer il y aura aussi peut-être des
voix lasse à sa facture qui sera mieux
connue grâce à
à la restauration lourde sans doute mais
que nous pourrons faire sur ce cette
pièce
il dit
ça
monsieur les îles puis à monsieur prix
mais je comprends que votre question et
va t'on refaire à l'identique la
verrière c'est ça on n'aura jamais la
verrière ancien c'est évident nous avons
aujourd'hui des morceaux que nous
n'avons pas à nous sommes en cours de
nous sommes en cours de récolte de ses
morceaux
nous avons donc ses morceaux ces sondes
et vraiment des des fragments il est
certain que cette verrière qui a déjà
été soufflée par l'explosion de la
poudrière qui se trouvait dans le
château en 1800 c'est pour ça qu'elle a
été reconstitué cette verrière donc
voilà elle déjà partiel nous ces
morceaux nous allons les récoltes et les
conserver les restaurer essayez
peut-être avec toutes les techniques
modernes aujourd'hui on fait tellement
de choses intéressantes et et je sais
combien notre scientifique par des
sciences dures las on développe
effectivement des matières et des moyens
pour pouvoir reconstituer notamment
pourquoi pas cette verrière parce
qu'elle prenait tout à l'heure à parler
de choses tout à fait intéressante qui
se passait à limoges aujourd'hui le
sujet que je ne peux pas le trancher
comme ça mais nous interrogerons la la
commission nationale du patrimoine et de
l'architecturé
la section générale 2
historique pour savoir si en effet on
refait à l'identique avec quoi en
restauration et avec quelle vestiges
pourcentage de vestiges qui reste ou si
nous sollicitons une création et à ce
moment là donc ministère de la culture
et des artistes
beaucoup d'artistes de grand talent pas
qu'en france puisque six lits à concours
ce sera un concours forcément
internationale voilà donc je ne peux pas
vous dire à l'heure actuelle si nous
passerons donc effectivement par une
commande publique ou si nous serons en
restauration
parce qu'elles peuvent élever - a ajouté
qu'il faut sur cette dernière quand même
pas ce que c'est
c'était dans le cadre de nantes est un
ensemble considérable de vitraux et ya
plusieurs ensembles contemporain déjà à
l'intérieur notamment ceux du coeur par
jean le moal à des années 70 qui était
un grand peintre des vols de paris qui
travaille à saint malo il ya ceux de dan
le chevalier et il ya ceux de musique
simon toutes les grisailles de la nef
dont il ya quand même plusieurs choses
or semblent assez
cauet mans et les grandes qualités et ce
vitrail et était quelque chose
finalement d'inachevé est ce qui est
râlant par sa complexité le fait qu'ils
aient des lancette xiième siècle l
effigie de lebron et de marguerite deux
fois et vtt rester avec un grand blanc
au milieu pratiquement en fait ce grand
blanc c'est un vrai problème dans la
dans l' équilibre lumineux et
chromatique donateurs la cathédrale qui
va pas quand on établit si on fait
travailler des artistes ou un programme
avec des objectifs probablement de
luminosité
de qualité chromatique pour retrouvons
en rapport avec la structure avec l'or
parce que la veille derrière norme
aujourd'hui lors la peau noire quand on
regardait parce qu'elle était en contre
jour en permanence
donc faisons des sujets qu'il faudra
lui dit et qui évidemment auront un
poids dans la définition le format du
projet est une autre question
je
on répond sur les expertises résistants
mais je peux vous dire que dès hier nous
avons nous sommes évidemment dès le
premier jour quasiment qu'occuper de
cette question et donc hier nous avons
diligenté un expert dans une entreprise
d'écrin à la cité qui donc à notre
demande a fait des prélèvements à la
fois à l'intérieur de l'édifice dans
plusieurs parties en haut en bas
et puis sur le paris pour voir si en
effet il y avait une pollution au plomb
pour pas en effet puisque les tuyaux
d'orgue contiennent du plomb comme vous
le savez voilà ensuite il ya les lé
constat qu'ont pu être fait par par la
rs est donc cette expertise plomb nous
en aurons les résultats très
prochainement
nous leur avons là encore demandé
d'aller accélérer un peu leur leur tende
expertise et autres caisses
[Musique]
je suis pas certain qu'on ait compris
bien parce qu'on l'entend man brésil
j'ai quand même sens du ciel voilé
meetic définition du budget vous
demandiez si on leur être out
non en fait on aura le budget au terme
du diagnostic et au terme des choix qui
seront partagées validé par le ministère
de la culture sur les propositions qui
seront faites
parce que bon en tête plusieurs
propositions il y aura des choix
peut-être différent pour l'or pour le
vitrail pour et puis il y aura peut-être
même des chemins différents pour le
traitement de certains parement
peut-être qu'on désire à garder certains
parents avec des stigmates de l'incendié
peut-être qu'il s'avérera nécessaire de
remplacer les pierres pour la stabilité
de justice donc il ya un choix l'alliage
un ensemble de choix que l'étude de la
grille télé qui permettra de présenter
ses comptes et qui fera l'objet d'une
discussion collégiale au sein des
ministères et probablement entre grandes
délégations à travers un avis de la cnb
à la commission nationale du patrimoine
donc à l'issue de sa bonté choix seront
sifflées dans le cadre du diagnostic ces
propositions sont chiffrées à la suite
de celle de rares un budget avec
probablement et possibilités
d'échéancier
les adjoints qui sera comme on le fait
en général et
et reliés aux priorités d'intervention
cette mesure va pas un mot sur le
financement et ce qui est à la chasse de
traiteur oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
préfet peut-être préciser d'une manière
plus voilà non mais c'est assez le
grille pain
je me trompe d'octo peut-être expliquer
d'une manière plus générale que donc le
budget ce sera le budget du ministère de
la culture qui est le maître d'ouvragé
de l'opération et qui donc à des lignes
de crédit pour intervenir sur les
cathédrales monsieur le préfet l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure donc c'est 20
millions d'euros par an en 20 ans et
donc là naturellement il va falloir
engager des dépenses plus importantes
qui vont nous permettre de restaurer la
cathédrale et puis dire aussi quand vous
l'avez vu que nos partenaires de la
fondation du patrimoine ont pris
l'initiative en plein accord avec le
ministère de la culture de lancer une
souscription pour concernant l'orgue est
donc là il y aura
en appel à la participation à la
générosité de nos concitoyens que ce
soient des particuliers ou des
entreprises pour pouvoir contribuer
prendre part à cette à cette grande
grande oeuvre que sera la restauration
de la cathédrale
en tout état de cause l'état assumera
ses responsabilités le ministère de la
culture sur ses crédits
qu'il s'agisse des murs ou qu'il
s'agisse éventuellement de l'ordre si la
souscription ne suffisait pas à financer
la totalité des travaux qui seront
nécessaires puis donc sur les procédures
je crois que parce qu'elle prenait la
très bien rappelé c'est vrai qu'il ya
cette manière de travailler un vous
voyez en matière de restauration de
monuments historiques que ce soit
l'immobilier où le mobilier
il y aller les professionnels de terrain
l'architecte en chef la drac et puis
après nous avons ces commissions sont
soit d'ailleurs des commissions
régionales soit je pense en l'espèce
effectivement plutôt la commission
nationale compte tenu du fait
j'ai eu de grandes cathédrales et donc
qui le moment venu se voient proposer ou
les parties de restauration possible
création d'éléments nouveaux ou
restauration à l'identique au fond c'est
toujours cette alternative simple et qui
rend un avis et à l'issue de cet avis et
bien les autorités compétentes
ministère de la culture prendra les
arbitrages nécessaires pour savoir dans
quel sens on va et donc vous voyez
encore une fois que tout ça conditionne
naturellement la question du budget
et c'est rosa
ah j'ai fait le conclat pendant que vous
étiez libérez moi j'en compte 10 + 2 à
venir voire toxiques
absolument
le
je suis jeune et c'est pas bien les été
renforcé leur pression
dans les jours qui viennent en fait il
faut un petit peu de temps parce qu'il
va falloir commander pas ça va être fait
dans les jours qui viennent il faut un
peu de temps parce qu'il faut commander
des effets spéciaux
il ya une assez grande hauteur on a
presque 5 mètres de haut
entre le sol et
et le tout face de la coursive qui ferme
le triforium et qui sert d'appui donc
ensuite ça va être un travail délicat il
va falloir déposé mana et remplacer les
éléments parce qu'on peut pas recréer
notre déséquilibre plutôt posé seins
étaient en enlever un autre voilà donc
c'est une question de
deux semaines sa peau lanceur site
j'espère qu'on pourra le faire pendant
la fin du mois de juillet le début du
mois d'août et on va aussi assurer le
clos refermer parce que la façade ouest
à nantes une façade qui reçoit beaucoup
d'eau c'est pas forcément la pression
n'est pas encore la saison des pluies
mais il faut qu'on ferme quand même ce
bâtiment pour les raisons de sûreté qui
encadraient les lots d'armes tanner
parce que ya pas mal de l'acrobate parmi
les engrais gîtes les cathédrales et les
giga aussi il ya aussi la nécessité de
pouvoir travailler de faire un
échafaudage qui permettra d'accéder au
parti traumatisé de l'édifice et des
analyses et voilà il y en aura d'autres
à l'intérieur
probablement aussi mémoire conduit le
têt pour le grand public
la province est de mettre en scène cette
restauration donc déjà on aura sur la
toile ne sera pas essayé de partir du
vent vous savez on a évité dans une
toile tout cet amas chez nous c'est
raide avoir gracié représentation des
mono et puis valérie on a aussi
diligenté un photographe professionnel
qui pourra effectivement
clementé définition une phase de
chantier et tout ça avant tout sa
dimension effectivement de communication
du grand public
donc on a on a vraiment ça aussi en
ligne de mire
et elle est en fait assez la fondation
du patrimoine james bien donc y aura des
points presse à une échéance qu'on ne
connaît pas qu'on va définir selon
l'oeuvre l'avancée du dossier mais vous
aurez des réunions régulières pour vous
dire comment les choses progressent
voilà merci volto nel
et réunion à 16 heures